[Music]
welcome back to the podcast thanks
thanks we have a lot to talk about well
we do since we last chatted right not
the least of which is I didn't even know
this because I've been at the house all
morning but Blake came in and he's like
hey you know do you know what's going on
with the fires and there was a big plume
over the hillside like just east of here
so it looks like maybe there's a fire in
Topanga I don't know it's very windy
today but welcome to fire season why
thank you
we were actually driving off and I'm
like I hope that's not where we're going
be like sorry you can't do it today the
roads weren't closed though no no it was
fine there was no engine no fire trucks
or anything I could hear well hopefully
we won't get evacuated in the middle
although that would be kind of like an
epic episode and regroup somewhere else
but good vibes only for that we are we
are in the midst of that season and I
guess you had a couple fire situations
during over man yeah yeah we did so on
there the first day of the bike ride I
was riding along and my crew stopped me
and they said look there's a fire nearby
it's about five kilometers away don't
worry the winds going the other way it's
not going to go anywhere near you but
you'll be able to see it and I was like
okay yet no worries and I'd seen like a
red flash earlier on but it was in the
night you know my I don't know if my
eyes are playing tricks on me or
anything I don't know force elucidating
so I just kind of went on fair enough
and then I came around the corner I've
no idea where I was at that point in
time I'm gonna get a tummy on the route
but I could just see this huge blaze it
just sees these hills just on fire and
I'm like oh my god and I'm like okay
let's just keep riding and not stuff me
yeah as if it's not a challenge enough
exactly and then on the run there was
another fire there was a car towing a
trailer and the trailer apparently
caught fire and then I'm actually saw
the car as it passed us on the run
course and it's completely got edge like
there was like death valley like it's so
hot the car was actually on fire pretty
much no it wasn't I wasn't dead felt
like that point I was past that point
but yeah it was there
the long stretch between the first climb
and the second climb along the along the
highway there sorry
oh right yeah yeah yeah I'll be able to
describe exactly where I was I do not
know negative places sorry well the last
time you were here was what was that
like a year ago yeah yeah like that but
November last year right because you
were getting ready to go do ultra math
correct which I want to talk about but
let's table that for now because the
bigger thing and the reason that you're
here is that you decided to tackle this
thing called uberman which I'm going to
make you define in a moment and I told
you if you survived it because despite
the things that I've done I have a I
have a hard time wrapping my head around
this crazy challenge yeah so tell us
what ever man is sorry even man as the
website describes is the world's
toughest triathlon it involves their
Catalina Channel swim I talking
kilometres sorry came after right use
miles am sorry I think Dan describes it
as the ultimate triathlon Odyssey oh
well there you go
that sounds even more amazing so it's a
33 kilometers whim from Catalina Island
across to the mainland 21 miles all
right 21 miles thank you and then you
ride it's a bit over 600 kilometers so
it's about 400 miles yeah yeah and then
you finish at the badwater basin and
then you do the bad water run course to
to Mount Whitney and you actually
finished at the trailhead so it's a
little bit past where the man would have
run finish it oh wow you keep going on a
little bit further I don't know how much
because I haven't done bad well that
last half marathon up there is
ridiculous I know so essentially it's in
the way that Ironman was originally
devised to test who who is the fittest
athlete the swimmer or the cyclist or
the runner by combining the Oahu open
water rough water swim with the ride
around Oahu and the
marathon this is sort of taking it to
the next level by combining three of you
know what's considered you know some of
the most challenging ultra endurance
events in the respective disciplines so
you have the Catalina swam which is
swimming from the island of Catalina to
Los Angeles on a clear day you can see
the island there are plenty of days when
you cannot it's quite a distance riding
your bike all the way to Death Valley
from Palos Verdes and then running bad
water I mean for somebody to just run
bad water and nothing else that's like a
bucket list challenge of a lifetime
you know that that people work decades
just to be able to tackle and complete
but to put it on the back end of these
other two things is truly astounding and
the fact that anyone can survive this is
extraordinary and not only did you
survive it you like crushed the women's
record by some ridiculous number of
hours right that was the first woman you
were oh you're the first woman to cater
yeah there's another women who do that
is a realize so she's like yeah so I'm
their trouble right and then Adam Scully
power who broke the men's record by like
40 hours yeah yeah right and for those
that are listening Adam was a guest on
the show in the very early days for like
doing some crazy distance run like all
the way across the state of
Massachusetts or something like that
right so that was really cool that the
two people doing it have both been on
the show yeah and if you go to that if
you go to the results page on the uber
man website it's just like one name yeah
yeah so what inspired you to even
attempt this sorry the Catalina's swim
and the bad would have run a two things
on my bucket list then I really wanted
to Derry sorry
Australia's very far away so you might
as well do them together correct you you
understand me sorry to step on your no
no no hey that's fine it's fine
um I guess like after epic five my plan
was to you know just chill to you know
relax to you know not do any other
insurance races and then I was like I
don't really feel like I'm done so then
I was like
hell I'll do ultraman hawaii and then
after that i was like well you know i
already started to percolate the idea of
doing over man when i think it was
around the time of epic five or you know
it's generally a couple of years ago and
then the idea just didn't really leave
me and it just kept kind of going and
going i was like well you know actually
I will have this fitness I will be able
to take it through you know I spoke to
my husband about it and said what do you
think
and he basically knows by the time I
brought an idea to him it's already
decided yeah so then that just the way
that I pick races is does it excite me
does it scare me and this definitely you
know excited me too there's no females
I've done it it looks like an absolutely
incredible challenge and it terrified me
I didn't know if I was going to be able
to finish it so I kind of fit my
criteria to give it a go before we dive
in and get granular on it how did like
in a global way how did the reality of
it match up with what you expected it
was it was really I kept describing as
an adventure like I never thought of it
as a race I never like there was no time
whatsoever that I was racing I know that
I'm sure people looking from the outside
in as a young social media you know
watching my little tracker as I was
going along it looks like I was racing
but for me I was like I want to move
through the course as quickly as I can
as efficiently as I can and my main
thing is I really wanted to test my
limits on how far I could go and how far
I could push myself and I didn't know
kind of my limits around fatigue so I
was like that was a massive massive
unknown for me so that was that was
quite you know quite normal to to
experience that in terms of like you
know kind of the older preparation in
the organization beforehand you know we
were kind of basically left to our to
our own devices one of the UM one of the
other athletes Jonathan his crew chief
Fiona she was amazing like she put
together all the maps for everybody for
the bike and you know because I had one
of my other friends of crude for bad
water before so they had all that
information and I had friends would swim
Catalina so I could kind of pull
resources from that so that was that was
really good I was basically just kind of
reaching out to my community insight
okay help me
well it's an expedition you know I mean
it's 556 miles so of course you're gonna
be tested in terms of the limits of your
fatigue but the only way to complete it
to the best of your abilities is to do
it with efficiency in mind yeah I mean I
don't know what racing that means yeah
otherwise yeah what I mean yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely it's it's not
something that I really feel like you
can you know have that racing mindset if
you don't have to go as fast as possible
because there's more you have to be as
efficient as possible to them and still
be surviving enough like starting the
run and in the last part of the run the
last half marathon is he said at Mount
Whitney that just it's brutal sorry well
I think I think one thing you know on
this idea of racing one thing that that
did distinguish your attempt this year
from what is transpired in the earlier
iterations of this Odyssey is that you
were kind of racing I mean you were
doing trying to see how quickly you
could do it as opposed to the
participants in the past you were like
I'm gonna do this thing and I'll just
you know I'll just take my time and
it'll take as long as I want I'm not
gonna worry about it like all you know
I'll take a day off or I'll do what out
you know what I mean like is there's no
urgency like the idea is to complete it
and I'm just not gonna be in a rush
whereas you were like not necessarily in
a rush but like how quickly can I
maneuver my body across these 556 miles
yeah I agree with that absolutely so
when you first had this idea and said
about preparing for this like how did
that affect your training preparation
did you did you do things differently
for this that you would for epic five or
ultraman's yeah sorry my big concern was
the swim because initially I'm like
that's a that's a long way and I hadn't
ever swam over ten kilometers in the
ocean before so in the start of 2018 I
did a 20 kilometer non wetsuit swim over
from Perth to Rottnest Island in
Australia and that was my yes you can do
it sorry I figured if I can make 20 case
I can make 33 because you know I'll have
a wet suit on you know is that as their
minds that I figured like you know when
you
training from marathon you can do 32 you
can do 42 like so extra bit we'll just
you're still there you just got to keep
moving much so that I've got there the
mindset of you know if you prove it then
you can do it basically so that's how I
kind of got the confidence of that and
then this year I always try and work on
my running because I was fine that's my
my weak leg in triathlon so I did a few
I think ended up doing about 550 K runs
throughout the year and 60 K and then
100 K run because in my mind I wanted to
make sure that 50 K was an intimidating
distance so if I had you know 30 50 K
left in the round I'd be like well I can
do that
that's you know that's fine so for me it
was a lot about kind of those mental
battles to get through right in terms of
the physical training that I was doing
when I first said to my coach Kate that
I want to do this her response was I've
no idea how to train you for this yeah
well that's fine you'll figure it out I
know exactly it's so unknown yeah so the
way that she would do it is that she'd
choose a sport a week and then just
overload that so have you know like
maybe four or five swims a week and have
that as the main focus and then I'd be I
did a couple times where I'd swim kind
of late at night I'll be getting out of
the pool like 8 9 o'clock and then be
back in the pool about like 5:00 5:30
the next day so it's that not really
letting your body have much break
between to kind of accumulate that
fatigue to get used to that as well and
before any of my races that I did I'd
always do a run the day before like you
know between like 10 15 K which is not
something I'd normally do before but
just never doing anything rested right
like pretty much doing it on tiredly yes
yeah absolutely
I mean okay some some 5060 K runs 100 K
run but that's different then I mean the
bad water is is twice that hundred K run
when you're exhausted ya know like
that's a whole different ball of wax
yeah I would imagine that a big part of
this is managing sleep deprivation and
how far and how much you can push
yourself with a reduction in sleep so
how did you
think about that and your prep and we'll
get to the race part in a minute but
just in your training did you like get
up in the middle of the night and do
stuff or try to go on two hours of sleep
or any of that because I when I did epic
five I got minimal slave and was still
quite functional and then I wanted to do
night shift I've done like really big
training blocks like 20 25 hours a week
managing with night shifts so I know in
my body in my mind that I can push
through fatigue and you know I'd be so
exhausted to the point you know I'd like
almost fall asleep standing up sometimes
so I didn't feel like I needed to you
know do those kind of
middle-of-the-night training because I
can still if I need to switch on a
switch I'm very very well very quickly
sorry
yeah and actually I'm I reached out to
iron cowboy and I said you know hey just
need some advice around you know sleep
and you know management management
fatigue and he's like you don't manage
it you just deal with it I was like okay
I'm like but that makes sense to me like
that you know that kind of that really
just reduced my anxiety around it and I
was like okay well I'll just have to
manage with whatever I do and sorry
during the race we just had different
sleep plans like could I go this long or
if not stop me and I'll have a sleep
beforehand or you know whatever so we
just had a bunch of different plans and
indeed that Wow
yeah I mean that's something that's
really rough for me to be able to like
have the aptitude to manage that that's
a talent in its own right thank ya yeah
I am I think my crew were quite
surprised because I'd sleep for a couple
of hours and then it actually be quite
refreshed from that I'm like that's all
I need and then I'll keep going for you
know 12 hours or whatever I know Terry
sorry how many crew members did you have
um sorry I had probably six core people
and sorry I decided I wanted to manage
them in ships because I didn't want the
same people the whole way through
because the crew fatigue is gonna be
incredible compared to my fatigue as
well they're probably get less sleep
than I do so I had like a night shift
and a day shift and then I had another
couple of people who like one guy came
in for the start for the bike and then
he had to go and then add another fringe
he I left my glasses on the bar and so
he over
with them as he said and then as soon as
he arrived he's like well I'm not
leaving till this is done
sorry yeah he was he was hanging around
as well they are they friends that live
here or did friends come from Australia
sorry I had well my husband came over
from Australia and then I had another
friend from Sydney and then I had other
friends one from Canada who drive down
the friend who brought my glasses to me
from San Diego and then some others from
Arizona and yeah in Pennsylvania that
I'd actually met at Ultraman last young
sorry kind of all over so this over man
thing is the brainchild of this guy
called Dan Burcu who is lives here in
Malibu and I've known him through
friends for a couple years and he's a
real estate guy he's actually the
landlord of joy cafe the restaurant that
were partnered in and I remember when he
first told me about this idea that he
had he was inspired
he turned 50 and he was inspired to like
get fit he came up with his crazy
harebrained idea and he was like I'm
thinking I'm creating this thing called
uberman you should do it now I was like
I don't know man like is it a thing like
are you really doing like all right I
think it just started with an idea like
let's see if it could be done it wasn't
like canonized to some kind of race but
he's now created some semblance of
structure around it where he hosts this
thing every year for what is the third
year fourth year since 2016 yeah but
part of this is that it's not an
organized endeavor where you show up and
there's a meeting and like you you're
handed a packet and here's the all the
things you have to worry about it's very
much choose-your-own-adventure like yeah
okay here's here's the thing this is
what you have to do now go do it all on
you yeah to figure that out so you were
right here and and you just what like
you just got to Catalina there's I'm
assume there's a start time and you know
everybody who's competing starts at the
same time or how does all that work you
just start whenever you feel like it
yeah
originally the start time was like 6
p.m. on the 10th and Adam he had a boat
captain that he'd organized and the vote
Kevin's like I can't do that time we
have to start on the 9th and all
Catalina swim start generally
around 11 o'clock midnight so studying
at 6:00 p.m. would be ridiculous because
you're going like against the tides and
it's not not a smart time to start
pretty much so there's kind of
discussion amongst the three of us who
were doing it and we're like okay so
what does your book captain say what
does your say when should we start you
know Jonathan who was the other guy who
did it he's like oh I want to start
earlier and then you know so it was
basically everything started different
behind I think I think Jonathan so like
maybe about nine Adam jumped in the
water about quarter to ten I was just
after 10 p.m. on the night that night
sorry it wasn't even we're all starting
at the one time it was just you know you
just start your watch off you guys right
so I'm particularly interested in the
Catalina swim leg portion of this
because my coach Chris as you may know
like a ot lo is doing a race in Catalina
I think it's March 1st oh I didn't know
that was coming up and he's like hey
we're all gonna do it you got to do it
and then we're gonna swim back he's like
you got to do it not like how many times
have I swam in the last month like I'm
not exactly you know fit for this but it
has my wheels turning a little bit not
happy I have plenty of friends who've
done that swim my buddy Hank wise who
was a teammate of mine at Stanford I
think he has the record and he does it
like I mean he's constant he does it all
the time yeah we doing it it's like a
laughs another thing he has the fastest
yeah the fastest crossing time but I'm
interested in in your strategy for that
and what it's like to swim like in the
middle of the night like yeah it's got
to be freaky yeah yeah it was it was
really cool actually I really loved
swimming at night so I've got a lot of
swimmers that I know who do the English
Channel swim so I always track them and
it's always like this big s-curve venge
and I'm like you know the tides push you
around everywhere and then I had a
couple of friends do Catalina in the two
weeks beforehand and there since it was
straight line I was like ah so this is
actually quite easy swim in terms of the
tides not pushing you from side to side
and things so that kind of reassured me
of okay I'm not going to be battling you
know the whole time so high tide was
about 8 p.m. sorry if I was to do my
time over I probably was started a
little bit earlier to catch a bit more
of the tide because well you know you
jump in the water you swim down to
doctors code which is where the swim
starts so you get out of the water if
it's an official crossing because your
feet have to be dry on both sides to
make it official but mine wasn't closed
in a wetsuit and yeah right yeah to be
super official you know wetsuit yeah
yeah and you know that to like touch the
kayak or the brooch or anything there's
all these all these rules after I've
observed isn't everything so I didn't
have didn't have any of that but I did
have a kayaker with me and because I've
done Ultraman and you always feet from
the kayaker I found that was like that's
what I'm used to I don't mind feeding
off the boat so that was that was really
handy but they've got so they just
positioned me between the boat and the
kayak and there's glory sticks on either
so I know and I breathe both sides so I
can see where I'm at in terms of on the
boat or dangling in the water on the
Barts yeah they just hang them off the
side of the bar yeah sorry yeah just
keep your sighting is really easy then
yeah especially if it's dark that's all
you see right exactly exactly like I
love swimming with kayakers because I
don't have to look forwards
I just looked to them because you know
I'm not doing the siding I'm not doing
the navigating that's the boat and they
the kayaker so those that's really I
quite enjoy that and how long did that
take to do you to do that's one 11 hours
54 yeah yeah Sartre was it was cold
there was um there was one particular
point I think it was for a few hours
where I was like swimming through all
these little so things are like little
kind of block looking things I don't
even know what they were someone said
that what calamari someone said those
salt things but they lit up from just a
light from the burrito I was allowing it
was just it's absolutely amazing sorry
but no justifying encounters with large
wildlife marine wildlife what is the
shark deal with that like has there ever
been a shark situation with the channel
swimmers I don't I don't think sorry um
but you know my very helpful friends
which I do you know I'm asking for a
friend
yeah yes this is not know my very
helpful friends were tagging me in
facebook parts a couple days beforehand
about a kayaker they've been attacked by
shock like shock it come on home that's
really helpful
but actually I said to my brick captain
before hand I said look this isn't an
official swim if there is a shark and
you're concerned about it pull me out of
the water but I can't allow it to get
back in and continue swimming so he's
like and he just laughed at me he's like
there's not gonna be shark it's fine
he's like I've seen sharks like half a
dozen times and majority of the time
when there's boats around there's too
much noise and they stir up too much of
the water and actually don't like it so
they usually they stay away so it's
comforting it is very comforting yes
yeah and what was the feeling and
hydration strategy for such a long swim
so every 20 minutes I had my kayak out
because I couldn't see so they had a
whistle that they blow for me to go over
to the kayak and it have some
electrolytes and water and then I'd use
like their baby food packets or some
gels just you know just something a
little bit different I try and keep it
pretty much liquids when I'm swimming
just because I can't digest a lot as
well
at one stage I do try you know have a
cookie and that didn't really sit very
well I was like all right we'll just
stick with ya because what we have when
I swim coz the first 20 kilometers was
really nice I could barely had to turn
my arms over there you know move
forwards and then there from then on it
got quite rough and so yeah I wasn't
feeling great and I felt a bit 6 but I
was still trying to get nutrition eggs
I'm like well this is only a tiny little
portion of this whole event right I
can't be completely depleted just yet so
when you're like 10 20 K's into it
though do you ever have a moment where
you're like holy like I'm way out
and you know there's no land anywhere
near me in in any direction I kind of
don't because I know there's a boat
there sorry if anything happens I know
that I'm gonna be safe so like my my
anxiety around things like that is based
around risk so if I was out there by
myself even with just a kayaker I
probably would have been a lot more
scared than if I had a boat with me cuz
I'm like well I know that if something
happens they'll be able to help me out
you know and then it'll be okay sorry
and and mentally I mean if you're riding
your bike or you're running there's
things to look at and you can kind of
you know entertain yourself with the
environment but in an event like that
for 11 plus hours you're just seeing
black like you're not seeing anything
like how does that affect
to your mental state like do you have
techniques for keeping your mind engaged
or what does that look like I just let
my mind wander all over think about this
and that and everything if I am starting
to struggle then I'll tell my kayaker
I'll tell you know I'll tell somebody
I'll tell my crew you know not feeling
that great and generally and I do this
on the bike and run I would have haven't
generally come up with some kind of plan
about okay well maybe we can try this
movement try that you know that might
better help something different I found
the time for that's three four o'clock
in the morning really really hard
because that was when I was getting
really tired and I just needed the Sun
to come up
sorry item in between my breaths I close
my eyes and like me I can have a little
micro slip between like while you're
swimming
well I'm sorry yeah yeah but then you
know once once the Sun starts to come
off and it gets light then you just
every juveniles you then you know your
body starts to wake up a little bit more
again and that was hard but the most
mentally challenging part actually had a
friend who does a lot of kayaking for
the channel he said in the last like
quarter of the swim don't look towards
the shore I was like yeah okay so of
course what did I do I looked towards
the shore but the thing it looks like it
never changes yes and you never get any
closer so I looked at my watch and all
this my gum and I was about you know ten
hours or something I'm like oh okay
maybe I'm about an hour away from shore
you know my you know get this done and
around 11 hours or something and my
kayaker even thought I was closer than
what I was and he said to me at around
eleven hours he's got oh this will be
your last feed then we'll be in and then
like two feeds after that he's like you
know this will be the last one I'm like
yeah you said that I can't believe her
and he's like I'm sorry which well we
both had that illusion that we'll closer
and then you just don't feel like you're
getting anywhere and because the oceans
so deep you don't have any of that
underwater navigation to tell you you're
still moving forward as well and I just
kept looking at my car can go no no he's
still stroking still moving forward so
it's kind of an optical illusion and
there's something about open water
swimming that plays with your perception
of time yeah cuz you'll swim I should
say I share my own experience like I
would think oh there it's been at least
like 40 minutes since I looked at my
garment or like I tried not to look at
it and unless I just feel so compelled
because you want to feel like you're
making progress but you'll have this
thing where you think an hour went by
and it's only been 10 minutes yeah and
and yeah having yeah having no depth the
the lack of like there's nothing in the
foreground to gauge the depth of how far
away though sure is yeah screws with you
yeah I mean I just remember just even
that Ultraman and part of this is
currents like when you start getting
into kiya ho and the current shifts and
it starts pressing against you and that
last you know mile feels like forever
yeah paired to the rest of the swim yeah
hi grace so alright you kid how you get
out and and typically in this in Prior
incarnations of this adventure the
person has done the swim and they're
like they call it a day right yeah they
at least take a break yeah but you just
skip on your bike start going oh I slept
for two hours are you doing how
indulgent it was funny because then met
me when I was walking out the path to
the RV and he's like how you were too
quick for me oh sorry I didn't I
obviously don't think he expected me to
be that quick and he said to NASA what
are you doing you know you're gonna stop
and have a sleep innings I'm like yeah
I'll stop for a couple of hours in his
uh quiet what what do you mean like you
know I saw you and he's like no one's
ever ridden on the same day of swimming
it was like well this is gonna be the
fist yeah because that's my plan what
was 11 a.m.
exactly so I wasn't gonna just hang out
for the rest of the day and not start
writing who do you think you're talking
to who I am yeah so because we had an RV
that we had for the whole hole right so
I had a bed to lie down on which was
amazing that was such a luxury yeah for
an event like this I had a toilet I had
someone to lie down somewhere they could
keep food and everything for the crew
yeah so my plan was always you know
sleep for a couple of hours just in also
for that you know still feeling in the
water your head just a bit you know
swaying and things trying to get that
feeling out which I didn't really have
but I didn't want that straightaway on
the bikes that'd be quite dangerous to
be right into a lot of traffic with that
I mean after being horizontal in the
water for that long just walking up on
shore is a weird thing yeah it was it
was because where you land on the beach
there's a lot of big rocks and a big
submerged rock so you have to be quite
careful when you're getting out of the
water as well so and the tide is quite
strong so it'll pull you back and then
push you forward quite intensely so you
have to kind of grab onto rocks and just
hold onto it but I had my crew help me
get out and just sat down for a little
bit and then had this you know group of
half a dozen women just going so what
have you just done what tell us what's
happening and what are you doing now and
that was the post-race weight and so
that's the same place where all the
channel swims and like if there's it's
at one specific there's a couple of
beaches yeah yeah that's one of them
uh-huh yeah so you take a nap and then
you get on your bike yeah and it's kind
of on you like is it just all right next
stop badwater basin and however you want
to get there you get there is there
there is there like different routes to
get there or you can just do what you
want or how does it work so um the guy
who did it last year Jared he had given
us the maps that he had used for the
race and from like his paper maps then
another girl Fiona I had tracked the
route and you know clarified with Danny
Jared you know is that where we're
supposed to be going so I had the routes
all uploaded onto my Garmin and we'd
printed it all out you know and had like
basically where we're supposed to be
going because it wasn't it wasn't like a
choose-your-own-adventure try and go
around because in my crew would have no
idea I was I would have no idea I was I
don't know the area at all I've never
been there before most of it sorry it
was just our plan was basically get as
far up the road as you can and then have
us another sleep sorry yeah it was just
you know say say hey go but I really
wanted to get out of the city I want to
get past Malibu I wanted to get more
into the countryside before I before I
stopped to rest so did you so your
impels Firdous then you went up north
through Malibu yeah oh you did oh wow up
to a PCH yeah yeah yeah so it was it was
beautiful I was going along PCH as the
Sun was setting as well which was which
is really quite quite pretty and then
eventually returned inland like once you
got up to a point mugu like where it
flattens out or do you know do you
remember
No yeah somewhere around there yeah that
was a tear and and what is your bike set
up for this like obviously you want to
be arrow but you want to be comfortable
right like how do you how did you figure
out how to get that sorted out I brought
two bikes over and sorry I came over
early and I did a 70.3 in September so I
brought my tri bike over for that and
then Michael my husband came over later
and he brought my road bike
au revoir so the original plan was you
know just kind of mix it up a bit I
started on my road bike just because you
know there's a lot of stops started in
traffic so I was like well that's
probably going to be the better bike to
ride through that section and then I
actually ended up staying on it for
majority of the of the black portion
there was a couple of parts which is
really nice and long and flat and I just
said to my career I'm like I just need
my shaver I just want to go arrow for a
while I want it be in a different
position and stretch my back out and
yeah that was that was really helpful
and there was one point when I got a
flat tire and my sheave and so that I
could just what bike sorry about that
was that was really helpful as well and
how did how did how long did it take you
to do the bike and how did that break
down in terms of sleep versus like you
know sections like how many miles would
you go before yeah sorry the first the
first day on the bike so in my mind it's
like one long continuous workday so I'm
still a very bad women where and how so
um I ended up writing about 150
kilometers and then I stopped for about
an hour I didn't sleep I was going to
but it was just nice just to lie down
I've not been moving just have something
different to aide and had a bit of past
I had you know something else and I got
back on the bike and I said to my crew
and I'm like it actually be really cool
to try and get to 200 kilometers tonight
and then I'll stop and have a decent
sleep so you know sleep further I think
was like about three hours or something
sorry high stakes it was late
[Laughter]
and then I was probably about like four
o'clock in the morning that eventually I
I stopped because you know my crew just
they were over there like we need a rest
we need to stop as well sorry you're
fine but they need a break well I was
getting tied
but I was also mindful of them as well
you know they'd been going you know
basically since I've got out of the swim
and they hadn't had a rest since then
and then because that was the day when
we went past the fires because then my
other crew had stayed back in rolling
hills where we had a Airbnb they ended
up taking about five hours to get
through the traffic because they closed
a bunch of roads so my night crew and it
up Tony and a half of my day crew as
well sorry yeah I'm kind of glad that I
did stop when I did so then they could
actually have a video rest as well so
two hours after the swim your first
legit sleep into the bike is a three
hour now yeah yeah and then how far how
long is the next leg sorry
getting out in two Nowheresville by this
place yeah yeah absolutely absolutely so
then I think I ended up I can't I don't
know where my Garmin is I'm gonna find
it when I get home so I can't tell you
exactly but I know I ended up over 300
kilometres because I remember stopping
at around the 300k mark and I said to my
career I'm like I've just done
surrounded Kaizen under 24 hours and
like that's pretty cool so it's pretty
had a little moment of a celebration
there but I remember riding down the
highway and my vision started to get a
bit blurred and my mood was really bad
and every time I mood goes bad I think
okay I need to eat something and I was
eating and nothing was changing I'm like
I heard this must be you know I must be
really tired and then my vision just
started to tunnel in and get a bit
blurred and all over the place so I
stopped and I said to my career I said
look I'm gonna need to sleep can you
just find somewhere we can stop and then
you know we'll be okay because we're on
a highway at that time but it was a lot
of space on the side and they ended up
just like stopping a couple of caves
down the road and said we're not off
this for another 20 K is we're just
gonna stop you here so I stopped and
slept for another couple of hours there
and then got up and got going again and
what is the nutrition like on the bike
and what kind of meals are you eating so
when I'd stopped initially I was having
like pasta I had some you know some kind
of other carbs but in there in the swim
my mouth ended up getting quite burnt
and I not getting really bad ulcers on
the side of my tongue because I had some
mouthwash but I probably wasn't using it
often enough and because I haven't been
in salt water Forex
here's a time like that before my mouth
just was like what are you doing to me
so after a while like eating became more
of a challenge because I was just so
painful to try and have anything sorry
I'd have things like watermelon and
coconut water and just things that I
could still get in and still you know
have something basically and then on the
bike I was having a mixture of
sandwiches I find they're always
generally really easy just to eat and
get down like you know peanut butter and
jam fisk off which is my new favorite
spread which is that oh it's in credits
this cookie butters fridge it is some
kind of like Australian Vegemite thing
it's no no it's a Dutch thing and I can
we can only find it in America so when
we come over we get that fits because
currently yeah yeah I told it some
others about they're like what is this
again and really like when to find this
yes it's just a different flavor
basically I was having that I was having
Clif bars I was generally eating bars
and things more at nighttime because I
find when it gets hotter I can't digest
as much food and you know as much things
keeping it more liquid during the day
yeah yeah liquid and you know I try and
eat as many solids as I can on the bike
cuz I know I can't have that amount of
solids when I'm running so I try and
kind of get because you're not just
eating for what you're enduring in the
moment you're you're eating for the next
day and the next day and the next day
yeah yeah next day exactly I learned
that from if you drive like everything I
did in that was for day five right so I
was like I can't stop feeling day 2
because I still I don't know how long
this is going to take me so I just have
to keep keep eating well this ride it
feels like oh you're just you're la is
pretty flat and you're going to Badwater
Basin which is the lowest point so this
must be you know kind of a straight shot
but there's 20,000 feet of climbing yes
there is yes yeah so it was it was
really really full-on and then the last
big climb was the first climb in the bad
border run as well that we did to come
down into the basin sorry you know I did
that in I think it's like the middle of
the day so that was full bore intense
Sun trying to get up that so what I
actually did in that is because the RV
was too big to be able to stop on the
side
Road we had a friend heard a car so I
every sort of phone stop and just jump
in that with the aircon just to cool my
body temperature down before then I got
back on and kept right kept riding yeah
I would imagine with every successive
hour it's getting a little bit hotter
yeah a little bit hotter so you just
drop down into the bowl of hell yes
right yeah because I am I got down to
the stove pipe and my vena
miscommunication with my crew because
I'd said to me you know from stovepipe
it's 40 kilometers to the Badwater Basin
was actually 40 miles and in my mind I'm
like Oh 40k yeah I can do that I can do
that
and I was talking to one of my friends
and she was like no you like it's like
7ek else like what and it just because I
was sorry to hive at that point I just
wanted to sleep but I just needed to
finish and then I could sleep because I
was getting I think I'm not finished at
4:35 13 at night so I wanted to finish
before it got dark and just have the
bike done sorry yeah I found that was
probably the most mentally tough part
and was the idea that you would sleep
the whole night and get up and run or
just get another couple hours every
weekend like just a full night of sleep
I know okay once I finished and then I
could didn't really say all right no
sorry I I think you're not getting in
bad another like three hours sleep
because we wanted to try and run through
the night as as much as possible because
you know bad what is really hot like
it's not as hot as July when but it's
July I think when bad waters actually
run but it's still kind of low 90s in
Fahrenheit so it's you know still so
quite hot so I started running it was
about 9:30 at night and then we ran
through to that big Oasis hotel yeah
well that's where they have the
headquarters for the bad water okay I
believe yeah we're thinking about the
same place yeah it's just weird it's
like this big hotel with a pool and
everything like that but it's in the
middle of nowhere
we built this here all these green
plants
nothing's dead am i dreaming me it's
very strange
yeah well it's one thing to ride your
bike you know across Los Angeles and
into the desert but once you get to bad
water I mean this is National Park or
State Park like it's preserved land yeah
and from what I understand it's not like
this is a permit it's not like a
permitted race so and and and I also
know that that you know the bad water
run itself and other races that have
tried to be conducted in this preserve
have had you know sir village like like
difficulties getting permits and it's
not easy right so knowing that the
possibility existed that you would get
there and they'd say what are you doing
you can't do this here
yeah that was very really yeah
absolutely
and I'm Danny do you have to play it
low-key or like did you have you know
sort of encounters with the Rangers
where you had to tell them what you were
doing or I know that Adam did because he
had his car follow him directly behind
him and they said you can't do that you
know what are you doing what's going on
and then they just left him alone after
that thankfully but yeah that was a that
was a very real concern and so you know
we were were quite concerned about you
know the amount of cars around me and
the amount of traffic and you know
because by that stage I had sells a car
that was kind of taking my crew off to
go and sleep and then coming back and
then we had the RV and then had another
friend who's kind of hang around and
we're like we can't have a big circus
around me yes exactly exactly and you
know like my friends from Arizona like
they are very very aware that you know
that was a possibility we could have
gotten kicked out and you know that's
the last thing I wanted I've come you
know this whole way of doing you know
three days worth of you know intense
swim bike and I didn't want to you know
just I see you later you can't do this
anymore
so actually did have the Ranger come
over and talk to us because I stopped
the run and had a rest at stovepipe in
the car park there and so the Ranger
came over and was like all you know
you're camping here you've been here for
a few few hours you know what's going on
and one of my crew talked to her and was
like no no it's okay
you know she's like all you never got
these they signs saying uber man you
know what's this about and he's like are
you know it's just I kind of remember
what he said but he basically just
played it right down and said no no it's
not a race it's okay you know it's just
I'm here you know supporting a friend
who's a paramedic is like I'm just
providing medical support just in case
of things needed and she's seem to
accept that right the nation thankfully
but yeah yeah the other way easily
easily could have yeah yeah sorry it was
it was a concern definitely in the back
of our minds that were like we just need
to try I mean because there was three of
us so it wasn't like it was a massive
hundred people running through all of a
sudden about it yeah still we need to be
careful did you have any crew meltdowns
no really I know of no I kept from you
yeah maybe that is a lot to ask
yeah that is a very difficult job yeah
he especially when you're not sleeping
at all yeah pretty much yeah when I'm on
the go the whole time no no it was um I
I feel like I pitched the right people
to come with me and they were all just
in a hundred percent you know no no
questions and everybody does the dynamic
worked with everybody everyone got along
really well thankfully because that's
always the concern you know they're
gonna be in fighting and you know people
just gonna quit and be like now I'm done
can't work with this person I'm out yeah
three of the girls knew each other
really really well so I just kept them
together cuz I'm like well yeah you know
he may as well sorry you know you're not
divorced I'm not divorced I'm still
happily married how does all of this
work with your marriage like it look
it's gotta put a little bit of a strange
definitely you know yeah it can't be
easy not to tackle something like this
no I'd be present for your relationship
no I it more comes up during the during
the training really than the rice I mean
the rice I know that well you can set
aside everything for that yeah yeah yeah
and I know that like he doesn't sleep a
lot even like and the biggest thing
we're talking about it afterwards was
being away from me was really quite
stressful for him because it's like I'm
not there I'm not in control it or no I
can't see you you know you're okay
and even in a couple days wasn't really
sleeping beforehand just the kind of
stress of it all but I'm
yeah when we're at home absolutely
because I mean Michael has a shell of me
really like in my big intense training
weeks like I'm a zombie
I'm you know I'm using all my energy to
get through my work days and then my
training and then there's not really a
lot left over at the end and I guess the
way that we kind of manage that is that
we know there's an end point to it it's
not like this is then gonna continue on
yeah exactly exactly it's like well this
is what its gonna be like it's gonna be
really quite you know intense for
probably a couple of months and then you
know I will do this and then afterwards
we'll have a bit of time together and
you know we'll have a bit of a holiday
together and then you know I've already
said like this is my last ultra for a
while so yeah
now it's his turn to like set aside
whatever it is you're doing yeah yeah
yeah absolutely
Vikki and it yeah he's over there is
nodding yeah big time yeah yeah
all right so ha it took you how long to
do the bike then um many days or
something no I just have it - just / -
it's like 50 something hours yeah Dan
originally said I got the bike course
record but I'm pretty sure that belongs
to Adam I yeah I have to check my my
times better right yeah all right and
you just immediately set about this run
yes yes do you do you see any of the
other do you see Adam along the way at
all like is there any encounters is Dan
at the like anywhere to be found in bad
water or the you're just freestyling it
yeah sorry I'm on the swim like I saw
their boats I saw Jonathan as I passed
him in the water and then on the black I
saw Adam once and I was so excited
because I just happened to look down
this road and there was a crew car then
I was like oh my god I haven't seen you
and sorry stopped and had a chat with
them and that was that was really lovely
and I didn't see him for the rest of the
time I saw him him and his crew that
already finished now heading off but
they came and found me on Mount Whitney
and you know stopped having a chat and
then Jonathan I saw when I was heading
out a stove 5 up the climb and he was
coming down on the bike so that was
really nice to go to give him a hug and
just you know wish him well um I saw Dan
on the first day and that's when he's
like what what are you doing why you
know
sleeping that's why please we don't
sleep in your room and what are you
talking about and then I saw him again
he came and found me on the run on the
so I ran through over the first climb
and then had a stuff in Lone Pine and
then he saw me there I know it was a bit
before on the second climb and then he
had to go back to LA so he wasn't it
there wasn't at the finish so he because
they've got this big like hammer thing
that they like for the athletes to be
able to like hold up at the end so he's
like make sure you get that I'm actually
get your little pin and you know uh I'll
see you later haha yeah like he he tried
to catch up with us today but I was like
well we still got the ave like I don't
know if we actually I would have pocket
anywhere and was just not getting bit
too hard sorry fortunately the same yeah
that's amazing
I mean for people I've said this before
on the podcast but for people that don't
know the bad water course basically
considered one of if not the toughest
foot race in the world 135 miles across
Death Valley they do it you know in in
the peak of the hottest you know time of
the year where temperatures can be up to
120 at times 130 like when you're coming
through stovepipe wells at like 2:00 or
3:00 in the afternoon I think they
started at different times now but
though in its original incarnation
that's what it was and and everybody you
know wants to talk about the heat but
what goes underappreciated
or unnoticed is how much elevation gain
there is it there is crazy
liming like there are massive climbs
throughout the course and it culminates
with this ridiculous climb up the
portals of Mount Whitney to like 8,000
feet and you just said you actually go
past that little camp right no because
it has to be just a little bit harder
like pretty much yeah we can't make it
easy for us apparently yeah I don't know
that's a state but you are doing it at a
little bit of a different time of year
so the heats
just a little bit less intense and I
don't have the 48 hour cutoff as well
sorry what
out of the run I was like there's no way
I'm gonna do this in two days which I
didn't need to I didn't have to you that
wasn't wasn't oppression the curse
exactly exactly yeah I'm like but you
were still doing the basically out on
the course for 12 hours and then
sleeping 2 to 3 or something or what was
the strategy no so we'd extended my
slate for the run I know I know I had
like four hours at one point so I think
I was up to five oh there's plan for
five anyway yes and when I got to that
weirdo aces place I think I slept there
maybe about four hours and then when I
got through to stovepipe again I think
that's maybe like a 3/4 hour because I
finished that and maybe like 11 12
o'clock so my crew were like well
there's no point in getting you out on
the road in the hottest part of the day
to start climbing right so you may as
well have a bit more of a rest and my
friend one of my crew members Willy he
has done like 250 K runs and things so I
was asking him for a lot of advice about
what do you think my sleep should be
like now and said you know run shorter
sleep longer and we'll get you through
and I was like okay well that you know
that made sense to me at this point
you're so deep into it an extra hour of
sleep would pay way more dividends than
like I got to be out there and then just
fall apart
yeah absolutely absolutely and like my
sleep overall I ended up getting a lot
more sleep than what I thought like we
went to doubt I got like over 30 hours
sleep over the whole the whole thing
sorry
you might mind I'm like that's actually
a lot of sleep yeah then we got so I
went over the big first climb and then
up to Lone Pine and then had a few hours
sleep there and then like woke up in the
morning you just check into one of those
hotels are you sleeping in our like an
Ave just in the car park somewhere yeah
just pull in hopefully no one comes in
knocks on the door and said what are you
doing we're gonna be there for a couple
hours so it wasn't wasn't too bad yeah
and I'm gonna do the next big climb and
then out of Lone Pine portals yeah yes
and then what I what I really noticed
when I was incredibly fatigued and
needing to stop my body would tell me
so like mentally I'm always generally
pretty switched on and I can tell you
what's going on can tell
happening but I would feel that my legs
instead of like running straight I'd
start like almost like I was you know
trying to ride a horse like my legs that
stopped swinging on the outside instead
of going going straight or I'd um I'd
suddenly just take a random step
sideways just for no particular reason
when my body's just like you start
acting like a drunk first off the course
yeah what so how long did it take you to
do the run then um I think another thing
about sixty hours yeah and what was the
hardest part of this whole thing like
where did you really meet your maker I
think was probably coming to stovepipe
in the the heat of the day that was when
I was really just mentally going this is
really tough now before that on that
section on the black that I was talking
about which was interesting because I I
was saying to myself I'm like well this
is what you'd wanted you wanted to try
and push yourself you wanted to try and
find your limits and it actually felt
relatively easy until that point just
like mentally to get through because I'd
been keeping my heart rate so low I'd
been feeling really well and so then
when I had that challenge on like okay
well let's embrace this this is this
what we really want but yeah probably
that that section when it was incredibly
hot and like in the Catalina swimmer you
can see where you're going to and you're
like oh that's only two miles away but
it takes forever to get oh sorry
yeah like just trying to trying to fight
and fight that sleep and then the other
time was coming in to the base of Mount
Whitney that little town there I can
remember what that one's called isn't
that Lone Pine is that Lone Pine ah yeah
tell you one continuous every day I
can't remember and a little cowboy town
yeah yeah yeah so when we're coming into
there I was so tired and I all I could
do it like I just had complete tunnel
vision cuz I have a crew member with me
at all times just for safety and because
I like company and so they've got a
headlight on and so I'm like to shine it
in front of me and all I could do was
look at that and I couldn't look
sideways I couldn't look at anything
else and I was just like almost falling
over and I'm like just get that out of
here and then finally my careers like
see that sign there that's where you go
into it like I can't even look up but
okay good please remember
yeah but never a moment where you're
like I gotta pull the plug like a kick
yeah I can't go any further
never no I when I did Ultraman Canada in
2014 I had a really a hell of a time
like I battled the whole way to get
through that and then I realized
afterwards I never thought about
quitting and I said to myself I'm like
well if you didn't want to quit then
that's now gone out of your minds like I
never think about quitting it's always
anything I'm starting I'm finishing no
matter which way or are so many up in
hospital and it's the crew pulling me
off the course sorry Wow yeah did you
use your buds at all were you listening
to anything or just good old school yeah
I don't listen to anything on the bike I
don't like that I like to be very aware
and attentive to everything around me
especially in a different country wrong
side the road for me don't really know
what the car drivers are like oh yeah
yeah I dress the opposite side of the
road not yesterday yeah sorry I mean
like I'm used to the drivers in
Australia I know what they're like but I
don't know what they're like over here
so I don't want any distractions most
calls with cars nor actually everyone
was really really good thankfully and
when I was at nighttime I had to cut my
crew we're driving behind me so I felt
felt quite okay with that yeah yeah and
I was I was really really lucky and then
on the run I had a crew member with me
at all times sorry
it was great because I had three days or
not talking to anyone like I get in the
RV I'd sit there and ate and then I'd
fall asleep when I get back up and get
on my bike and so I'm like all right
well let's chat like let's you know but
never like hey maybe I could listen to
some music or like an audio book or
something like that - just like engage
my mind in a different way especially
when you know the fatigue sets in one of
my friends had a spay cavity Chuck down
his top so we were able this into a bit
of music so that was pretty cool and
then in that really long stretch before
you get to Lone Pine my friends in the
car like they were cranking the tunes
for me as well sorry there was there was
a couple of a couple of moments with
some music that was really fun it's a
party oh it really was it was great well
I'm getting the impression that this was
all just a casual affair and you just
knocked it out like you're so low-key
it was like it was hard but I did never
felt like quitting and it's all good
nobody could dance like it was it hot
enough with the bike huh I'm like no no
the bike was well challenging like I
thought it is a really really Haj hot
rice I mean stands like disappointed
that you weren't more tired or something
I think brother that I look as bad as it
probably should have but I have such a
good poker face in the bike you can't
tell when I'm suffering like I won't
show any signs really until I'm like way
way down down the rabbit hole sorry and
I got managed to get on to everything
before it ended up being that bad I mean
I did have struggles like I you know my
mouth was really painful like I'd have
I'd have to use mouthwash quite
regularly and then you know you'd tell
what I'd used it cause I'd be like
screaming cause it'd be so painful my
wetsuit tore strips off my neck so I had
this some because I taped it that lasts
about 10 kilometers yes I had like 25
Kay's with no tape no nothing and my wet
suit just like showering the hell out of
me sorry I mean you know my paddlers at
once say she want me to do something
about that I'm like well what are you
gonna do like there's nothing I'm gonna
have to put up with it so then on the
bike turning my head was quite quite
hard to do and I'm used to turning right
to look for cars instead of turning left
so that was that was kind of screwing up
yes yeah totally do you know who you
know raw sadly yeah yeah did you see the
pictures of what his neck look yes yeah
dude he literally had Matt you know I
just had duct tape taped all around it
yeah
don't like try to keep that from getting
worse but it was gnarly I did I don't
know what what you could do about it
like yeah once it starts well that's it
yeah just managing it like you're not
get it to go away yeah brutal yeah
well you can only train so much right no
matter what event it is that you're
preparing for so when I look at this I
just see somebody who who is very fit
and has a certain amount of talent but
whose real gift is this extraordinary
capacity for pencil fortitude right the
fact that you didn't lose your shed
that you're a poker face that you can
keep it together when the rubber hits
the road you know like all these things
over such a protracted extended period
of time through every type of condition
and situation that could get thrown at
you demonstrate somebody of great
composure so to what do you attribute
that or do you have like do you train
that do you have techniques for how you
develop that level of focus and
fortitude like what does that look like
yeah sorry
um if you ask my parents they would say
I was very stubborn and growing up and
so now I call that mental strength
likeness isn't it mr. Brandes correct
correct is reworded it um yeah no I work
hard on my mental strength I as soon as
my coach says to me okay so we're gonna
start training for whatever the event is
specifically from this time I start my
mental and physical training at that
time and that's just a decision that
I've made in myself so every session
that I do I'm thinking about the event
I'm thinking about the finish line I'm
thinking about the process and I'm gonna
be going through you know to get to that
any session when I'm training that I
find really hard it's kind of a mental
battle to get through I'm reminding
myself I'm like okay use this in the
race you know you've got through this
how did you get through it what did you
do you know like use all these
strategies then you can you can transfer
into when when you're doing the race so
I kind of I don't see physical and
mental training and separate I see it as
both together and they need to be done
simultaneously so yeah I definitely do
that and I do have strategies and
mantras that I use throughout events as
well and yeah I was you know saying to
my crew at one stage I'm like okay so
this is a mentor I'm using now and this
is what's happening now because I'll
just tell them everything that's going
on in what are the maestro's so um one
of them especially when I first start is
don't be hero so like don't go out too
hard be conservative you know pull back
and I just kind of imagine like I just
tucked my ego away in my pocket
sorry yeah I just don't know don't let
myself get out of control because you're
gonna need that energy towards towards
the end yeah so that's that's kind of my
main one that I use for that
when it's hot I use a few different
things as well so my previous coach
Craig he'd said to me you know you've
got to stop complaining about the heat
and saying how badly it affects you
you're gonna have to figure out a way to
be able to manage it so I was like okay
all right you know how am I gonna do
this and so I use a couple of things I
every time you know I can feel the Sun
and if it's really intense I just you
know express gratitude and I'll say you
know thank you thank you for you know
for a son and I imagine it giving me
energy and kind of like you know power
me a lot of my ginger nests really you
look at my page yeah I like I should not
be in the Sun in bad water should be
doing this in Scotland yeah Dan can
create every man in Scotland cold
weather all the way yes I'll do that
and I never verbalized that it's hot I
never say it out loud and if anyone says
it to me I always respond automatically
and I just say it's not that bad because
for me if I speak it it's my truth and
so then nobody you know I don't ever
want to you know just say it say it out
loud and I'm always always checking in
with myself all the time how you're
feeling how's things going is anything
hurt is anything going on you know can
you adjust anything you know you need to
eat something you need to drink
something and you know all of all of
those things just constantly doing doing
all these different checks and and
talking to my crew as well like you know
I'll be feeding them information you
know if I stop I say okay so this is
what's going on for me this is what I
needs it's what I need you guys to do
and then kind of using that energy as
well often it's the other way around
though where the crew has to kind of
compel the athlete to eat or drink is
the athlete doesn't want to and there's
a there's there's sort of a tete-a-tete
you know that goes on yeah but it sounds
like you're pretty in tune and you're
not the person who's resistant you know
all of that no yeah I feel like I've
learned over time that I just can't like
I just have to you know I have to give
in to that
yeah and you know at some stage I do say
I don't know what to do I need you to
help me make a decision here so but
again like I've already told my crew
that I might get to that point and then
they might have to help me and then you
know they're they're amazing then they
step up so well a couple things
so you finish you finish this race the
first thing I want to know is like how
did that what is the emotional you know
experience of completing something so
massive and what second to that and more
importantly like what did you learn
about yourself
yeah sorry finishing I finished during
the day which was incredible I was the
only one who managed to fish in daylight
the other two finished at nighttime and
when I saw Dan and Lone Pine I said to
him I'm like specifically I've seen
pictures of Mount Whitney I want to see
it in daylight it was like yeah perfect
I'm not finishing about like two o'clock
in the afternoon so it was it was really
really cool um I didn't because I
haven't been there before I didn't know
specifically where the finish line was
so it's kind of like going okay where is
it
and one of my crew is like wow that's
everything I through that I'm like yeah
it's okay I see it it's okay like I
don't need to hurry
nobody else around I'm not racing for a
finish time yeah but I actually had like
you know all of my crew there and then
just quite a few random people who
they're like we know something's going
on here and we want to know when we'll
want to be a part just people that we're
hiking
yeah yeah yeah yeah and there's one
woman that said I'll you know we saw you
coming up when we're driving so she's
like so we knew we had to wait around
for another you know in 10 20 minutes to
to see you finished which is really
really special um I was just I don't
know I can't even really describe the
feeling that I had it was just absolute
amazement that I'd actually I'd done
that like this was you know I'd managed
to complete this goal I was yea really
really happy really overwhelmed and just
full of love for my crew as well like
you know they played a huge part to be
able to get me get me through to the
finish it was just it was amazing and I
just sat down I was like wow like it's
just it's I don't even think it's still
sunken in that I managed to do that and
work Rosie yeah yeah absolutely
your video of you completing it or video
taking along the way yeah I had a
documentary and the guy doing it yeah
yeah yeah so that that actually came
about completely random so I had a one
of my crew friends it's his work friend
and he wants to get into documentary
filmmaking so he contacted me and say
can I do this I was like yes I would
love that so yeah I don't film is in the
works
it is in the works yeah Tori cool yeah
yeah and we just have to wait and see
where that ends up what happens with it
we don't have specific plans so we'll
just have to have to wait and see so
that'll be yeah I don't we pretty
amazing to be able to actually relive
all of it as well because I know I will
have forgotten a lot that actually
happens like my fuzzy fright like
remember ever things what are we cool
you get a pass yeah and and back to the
question like what did it teach you
about about yourself and also just about
potential and the capacity for the human
being to do amazing things yeah I mean
before this I developed the belief and I
still believe it that there actually is
no limits to what humans can do it's
only the limits that we put on ourselves
like physically mentally what we think
that we're capable of but I honestly
believe that you know if you put your
mind to it and physically you're able to
then there actually is there's no no
limits to what we can do which its kind
of scary if you think about it in that
way yeah what what can do and in terms
of what I learn about myself the main
takeaway that I have for now
I mean I need probably about like two
three months to reflect on this and
actually really kind of dig in and find
out what it what it all means but when I
first went to the you know we all got
together for a dinner before uberman
started with athletes and crew and Dan
and I walked in and for the first time
ever I didn't feel like I didn't belong
there like I always have this kind of
imposter you know you know someone
walking with a groove and feel like oh
where's the athlete who you know Who am
I supposed to be looking at and you know
it's kind of be like I don't I don't
belong here I don't fit in here and it
was the first time and actually caught
me by surprise because I hadn't really
thought about it and it's when I have
urged my place here I belong here so
that was that's cool because the
imposter thing is something you've
talked about before and I think it's
something that you were battling when
you came on the pocket totally oh my god
how the biggest meltdown after was just
going through the
you two come on here I mean seriously
like oh yeah no Danny and I were talking
about it and we're both like well if no
one listens at least our mums alive I
got so many messages afterwards it was
beautiful yeah yeah no absolutely yeah
well I'm good I'm glad that you've
overcome that thank you thank you that's
nice that's a big thing yeah
Nora it is can it own it and be like
yeah this is where I belong
yeah yeah totally well I think you've
played your your girl card your girl
power card sorry there's anything else
to prove I mean does it leave you
thinking like what's next and now I
gotta go do some Curt other crazy like
that's sort of the the allure and the
danger right like oh I did this so now I
can go do this and you can kind of chase
that dragon your life yeah at what point
is enough enough or what is it that you
still need to learn or you know is it
just about the experience or is there
something unhealthy about kind of making
your whole life about these crazy things
yeah sorry I mean I've done three years
worth of ultras so did epic five never
launched me in Hawaii and now uber man
and I know if I try to train for another
old trial it's gonna really just destroy
my brain I'm just not gonna cope with
that so I already knew before I did this
this is gonna be my last ultra for a
while like I just really need to step
away from it because like the training
for this is really mentally taxed me
because also work has been really really
busy really intense I haven't had kind
of any downtime at all in my life so I
just I really need some time and space
just to you know reduce reduce the
mental load reduce that training and get
back to a little bit more of a sense of
normality in my life I will still like
do races and do events but they just
won't be won't be as long yeah yeah I
mean I'll you know I'll come back to it
but just not for a while right after the
thing was over was there like a dinner
with Adam and Dan at like were you able
to swap war stories and you know have a
meeting of the minds with everyone or
did everyone did you just split and like
I'm done
like network yeah sorry I mean Adam came
in saw me on Mount Whitney and he was
flying out that night because he could
only come away for certain amenities you
know got family and had to get back to
and then Jonathan finished a few days
afterwards sorry we were all kind of too
far apart really
yes sir I mean I had like my crew we all
hung out that night and that was that
was really nice just to sit around and
chat and just you know talk about
different things that had happened and
really funny things that had happened
and just random things and then had
another couple days just with a couple
of crew members as well so that was it
was nice not for everyone just to
disperse suddenly and I'd be like oh
hang on what what's yeah so we had that
kind of decompression time together as
well it was really cool what was the
most unexpected thing that occurred okay
one of my crew members decided to bison
cost you which was fine except one he
brought was a clown and I'm terrified of
clowns uh-huh and he had like this mask
on which made him look like he was from
aged like I was at one stage along the
road and I was with my friend Mary and
we both look over and we're like there's
a clown over there oh my god what's
going on and we were panicking did you
think you were having a hallucination at
first I was yeah yeah but then I always
check with whoever I'm with him like can
you see that too and she's like no I can
see that and we're like okay for now but
then when are they getting more and more
anxious and then just feeding off each
other's anxieties because we didn't know
cuz she thought she'd seen one of my
crew members who it was right so she was
confused at who was I had no idea in my
foggy brain and then she said to me he's
like it's okay it's okay he's gone and
then I was on the road behind us we were
we were and we ended up like having to
signal to mother curry and in the cab
just like shut it down shut it down like
I was almost in tears off so um yeah I
mean you know Hugh felt really bad
afterwards he's like I'm so sorry I
didn't think you into the other things
that were surprising to be honest like
nothing surprised me like I mean how my
body reacted to fatigue
that was something I hadn't experienced
before but everything else throughout my
like ultra racing that I've done I
expected every single thing that
happened and was I would a plan for an
able to deal with it basically in
advance sorry I wasn't sure how my faded
go in terms of swelling so we had a
couple different bike shoes but they
were fine on the bike and then my feet
started swell on the run so like we cut
the sides of the shoes and my feet could
spread sideways and then they started to
get too small so we had another pair of
shoes to size up so like we kind of had
pre preempted everything that happens so
that actually was no big surprises yeah
yeah well hats off thank you that's
crazy
yeah I believe you do it I'm not either
can I and did it swiftly and and
seemingly yes difficult but without all
kinds of crazy unforeseen vol obstacles
yeah things going haywire yeah wrong and
all that kind of stuff that usually
happens I was incredibly lucky with that
yeah I mean things have the potential
gone completely sideways yeah you know
the RV hits a deer or like yes stuff
happens yeah yeah absolutely yeah like I
could have you know broken both my bikes
not be out of ride like right hurry
Nori's yeah exactly well last time you
were here
you were about to leave to go to Hawaii
to do Ultraman Hawaii yeah Ultraman
World Championships and you completed
that but that didn't exactly go to plan
right what happened
yeah sorry um because of the lava flows
I had to change great course yes our day
1 and day 2 were very very different so
just to put a pin in that for a moment
that's because of the volcano and the
lava flow it's like there's a whole
section of the ultraman course that
literally got you know wiped out with
lava flow yeah so they had to completely
reconfigure the entire thing yeah sorry
at the the pre athlete briefing they
said look we could still use most of the
old course but we're gonna go through a
community where half the residents
haven't been able to get back to their
houses we don't feel comfortable about
taking our very expensive bikes now race
through that area and
like I totally respect that sorry that's
why they decided to to also change the
course and I mean hats off to them they
gave us a course like potentially they
could not even been how to do that so
yeah I was I was quite impressed with
that so their day one swims still the
same and then we rode like out towards
volcano and then they took us back in to
where the swim finishes that was the day
one bike so you do that climb and then
you send it no basically get me the base
of the climb and then trainer and come
back yeah so we didn't have to write do
that last page yeah that makes it a
little easier that climb is sort of like
the the last portion of the Catalina
swim where you have headwinds and you're
going like two miles an hour up that
means crazy takes forever yeah and I had
a really nice tailwind coming back and
the wind had started to really pick up
just before I turned and I was like now
I understand what the wind would have
been like if I had to climb volcano like
it was pretty intense yeah
and then day 2 was where like everybody
beforehand was talking about day 2
they're like you know there's 4000
meters climbing you know we have to go
over saddle roads then we have you know
just everyone was on edge panicking
about day to basically beforehand and
that was my stress as well like I just I
didn't know if I was gonna get through
it
and you know after day one I set my crew
down and said look we have to be as
efficient as possible like racing car
drive efficiency every time I stop for
anything that I need because I can't
waste any time whatsoever
and they were amazing like they really
stepped up I looked at my um my Garmin
file later and I had eight minutes out
of the 12 hours that had actually
stopped off you know off the bike not
moving time so that was that was pretty
incredible for this Saddlebrook so
basically did you take the old highway
north like how did it work so I went up
the Queen K and then turned off it as a
Waikoloa I think and I went up from that
yeah yeah yeah see climates work low and
then yeah down and then climbed over
over saddle Rouge and then went up to
Waimea
right sorry like and then you do the
Kahala noise I had to take the collars
ouch because they there was another race
that had been through and they decided
to pull the permits after that race
because yeah like people were like
playing music really loud at 3 o'clock
in the morning and dropping rubbish and
there was a lot of a lot of political
issues around that so then it up just
taking us back along the main highway
that connects through the Queen came in
up to Harvey and then you turn to Harvey
and rode up to the finish up there so it
was a literate finish line as well then
in previous right so this took a little
bit longer than you anticipated yeah so
I got to their 12-hour cut off with two
and a half days to spare so I didn't
didn't make day to cut off I think out
of the eleven women like four of them
made it it was yeah that I think was
about like 35% of us that didn't make
day to cut off it was yeah it was pretty
pretty brutal day and in my mind's like
I was looking at the saddle right I'd
ridden it I'm like okay that's really
you know it's really long it's hard but
to me I was like okay so what's after
that because you know everyone's like
saddle roads that are road ones like
that you're fatigued enough then you get
to the point and then you've got another
20 K climate no one's ever thinking
about it because you can't see it on the
map because it doesn't have as much
elevation but it's still kind of like a
volcano climate is still having to climb
as well so yeah I mean I I've read as
hard as I could but I didn't get there
basically was was the answer right and a
lot of people would have just pulled the
plug and said I'm done
but you were still within a time frame
that allowed you to complete the
complete the event just do it as an
unofficial finisher yeah so you did the
run that I yes I did yeah yeah and the
run course was the same yes yes
yeah the run course is exactly the same
um like on their on the bike because an
epic five I didn't have any nutrition
problems I'm like all these problems
that I'd had in previous ultraman's I'm
like right got it sorted no problems but
because the intensity level of my hair
is higher
I had nutrition problems again I'm sorry
on the bike like I was vomiting for
about four hours and I would have taken
little bits but not as much as I should
have or could have really and so then on
the run I started running and within
about half an hour I was dry reaching
and throwing off and
like what am i doing and I feel like
that was probably like the most mentally
hard part about that because I kept
saying to myself like why are you doing
this like there is nothing that's going
to change the outcome of you finishing
the run today versus not finishing and I
just kept running I'm like okay well you
know I don't have a good answer to stop
so therefore I'll just continue until I
find one and of course I know that I'm
never going to find one it took me it
took me about two hours to actually
figure out the answer to that to that
question I just kind of kept it hanging
around like why you're still going I'm
like I don't know so I'll have to just
keep going and then eventually I came on
the conclusion of I don't quit and if I
did quit today then what was the point
of yesterday what was the point of
battling all day
basically where's you know from as soon
as we started like always battling to
try and get to the finish line in time
then what was the point in doing that so
that's why I ended up finishing the run
I like that I think a weaker mindset
would have been I don't have to do this
like why am i doing it as opposed to I
need to find an answer to quit versus I
need to find an answer to keep going
yeah I mean yeah yeah definitely that's
amazing thank you so you finished it so
here we are we are on the cusp of the
10th anniversary of epic 5 yes and as we
both know
Rebecca Morgan who was here last time
who is the race director and the Angel
of all things
epic 5 has something planned to
celebrate this 10th year and that plan
entails something she's calling epic 10
yeah just basically doubling to
celebrate that the decade-long race
she's doubling the distances so it's
doing to Iron Man's per Island all right
is that how it works
I'm not entirely sure we're actually
catching up with her you know in a
couple of days so I'm looking forward to
that I think they're gonna include a
couple of other islands like I'm not
sure they might be doing like two on
Kauai maybe two in a while whoo I think
they're going to lanai as well
maybe wanna Molokai yeah I'm not
entirely sure how it's gonna work out
ultimately it's ten Ironman see ten days
on a variety of islands there's there's
injure island travel involved uh-huh
yeah so does this tempt you okay so
that's interesting I think that's very
telling I think it's a healthy response
like yeah the I wouldn't I wouldn't
begrudge you if you thought coming off
of uberman like oh my god I just blew
the ceiling off what I thought I could
do like this is the logical next thing
to do
yeah yeah for me there's a couple of
reasons sorry one realistically I
actually don't know if I'd be fast
enough to then get through each day to
get to the next Island for timewise
because I'm a very very good at going
long for a long period of time but I
don't have a lot of speed
correct correct yeah I just will not
stop and yeah the other thing is I just
need a break like I just need like that
mental break and the idea of putting
myself through another huge training
block it just it doesn't appeal to me at
this point in time but in saying that I
have such a Rebecca I'll go and help her
out sorry
yeah I do plan to be there but just not
as an athlete right yeah all right well
I think it would be good and helpful to
people that are listening to provide a
little bit of wisdom and guidance for
for the individual who is inspired by
what you've done and accomplished but
it's struggling to get off the couch or
maybe trying to figure out how to do
their first 5k or step it up from you
know the 5k to the 10k to the marathon
like how do you you know communicate to
that person yeah absolutely I I love
these questions because I get a lot of
people saying especially after the
podcast I did with you that you know
they've started because they heard me
and they heard my journey and heard my
story so that was yeah oh my god it's so
good and the other one is you know I've
told my daughter about you and I was
like oh I just touched my
in my mind somethings better than
nothing so for me I take all of the
decisions as possible out of my day to
make sure that I can be successful in my
sports so first thing in the morning
alarm goes off I don't even think about
getting up I just get straight up all my
clothes are already out ready to go
put them on get out the door no decision
fatigue correct correct because I mean
my job is incredibly stressful at times
and I can get home just be mentally
exhausted knowing I still have a session
to do sorry if my clothes are already
out I don't let myself sit on the couch
I don't let myself have an out I just
have okay this is what you're doing and
then you can stop so that's that's the
way I kind of manage it so I think for
the people who were you know trying to
start to do something it would be not
aiming for perfection not aiming for do
something every day it's like you know
if you do something three days in a row
take one day off that's not a failure
okay start again the next day don't
because I feel a lot of people like you
know if I don't do it a hundred percent
then I'm a failure animes will not even
try sorry yeah you know if you I don't I
don't look like that person that I see
in the magazine who is crossing the
finish line and so why bother yeah
exactly I mean I know before I did
Ultraman Canada I looked at the picture
of the athletes and I said to myself
like does anybody there look like me and
then that informed me of like ah
actually they're not all super fit super
human looking people maybe I might be
able to give it a go so I absolutely had
that as well
and you know I still still do since some
extent because I have that hang off of
like I don't look like those people in
the magazines yet I can still do these
things so you know why can't other
people as well and I think it like we're
sort of presuming that everybody knows
your backstory because we covered it in
the first episode and everybody should
go back and listen to that because I
think it helps contextualise all of this
but it's not as if you were you know
crushing marathons and triathlons your
whole life and grew up is this like
hardened athlete this is a new this is
still like a very fresh pretty new thing
in your life yeah absolutely
absolutely I mean I started triathlon in
2005 sorry and before that I was only
just doing things for a bit of fun
ever run before yeah I do too Iron Man
for the first time 10 years ago sorry
yeah I'm I'm still a baby at this I'm
still very you yeah that's such a
tortoise response if somebody's like
well that was a decade ago like it was
only 10 years ago and I think it speaks
to this this kind of myopic view that we
place upon our potential in the sense
that we tend to focus on what can be
accomplished in three months or six
months and if we can't do it then then
why bother or it's too hard or I'm not
good enough and you know being the
tortoise that you are it's like take a
long view on this like it didn't you
didn't do over man right out of the gate
like you've been building towards this
for a very long time yeah and as any
good tortoise will tell you you just
keep moving forward it doesn't matter
how slowly you're moving as long as
you're along that trajectory that's
getting you closer to that person in
that place yeah yeah one of my crew
actually said to me is like you know
just relentless forward motion and I
kept thinking about that all the time
like just forward motion just keep
moving forward right it doesn't matter
how fast the slurry you get there in the
end
which yeah I teach yeah are you dealing
with any like post-event like mental
letdown like it's gotta be you have so
much energy going into something like
this and then it's done and then there's
this vacuum yeah yeah I I don't and it
was really interesting sorry after epic
five I didn't have it either and I kind
of reflected in like why why did not
have that like I've had that before
where you have this big kind of crash
come down and I'd realized I'd actually
done some work mentally beforehand to
kind of equip myself for what it was
gonna feel like afterwards as well again
like kind of looking back I didn't
realize I was doing at the time but what
I do when I'm in that date fatigue
really really struggling is I think
about what it's gonna be like after this
is done and actually get quite excited
I'm like I can sit on the couch after oh
it's Netflix I can hang out with my
friends and I get really like that's
gonna be amazing sorry I just um how
long do you know you'd be generally
about a month I don't really do a lot um
and also I think because we're still
traveling at the moment like we're not
home yet sorry that
kind of hasn't reality hasn't stepped
back in again yet but yeah I probably
won't be physically active probably
about a month because you know like
standing up and walking around and
walking up a flight of stairs I'll be
out of breath like my body is at rock
bottom if I try and do anything right
now I'm just gonna like make myself sick
or something so I need to just give
myself that time and then I mean in that
time if I want to do something then I
will but if I don't then I don't put any
pressure myself to have to do something
so that's kind of the mental refresh
they give myself as well right right
right yeah well I think that's a good
place to put a button in it for now
until you go do some other documentary
comes out you can come back talk about
that yeah
but any final parting words of wisdom
for the weekend warriors and athletes
alike yeah yeah so I guess you know back
to what it would I do like if something
scares you have something excites you
then then move towards it you know if
that's a goal that you're setting to
three years in advance I completely
relate that's exactly what I do but you
know just make steps to move towards
towards that end goal just yeah it's
really really cool awesome thank you
you're great I love I'm glad super
inspiring what you've done and you've
created this amazing example for all
kinds of people not the least of which
are young girls who are looking up to
you and getting a lot of inspiration
from the path that you've blazed so
thank you for that thank you and if
people want to connect with you where's
the best place for them to go yeah sorry
I've just started an athlete's page on
Facebook one of my friends is it
convinced me that's what I need to do
I'm like okay so that's Melissa Yuri
ultra endurance athlete because my
private page is just getting bit clogged
up so I don't want to move things off
that my Instagram is at rang ml and say
Mont we don't really used Twitter that
much and my blog is Wrangham l WordPress
calm cool alright thanks so much thank
you come and talk to me again oh I will
all right peace plants uberman
[Music]